des colliers fogel j'ai envie d'une
question
coucou isabelle matane se faire virer un
jour d'rtl à cause de tes pmp un
week-end ça me va bien arriver ce soir
c'est imbécile à côté il a pris mon
portable et l'envoyer un truc érotique
un de mes grands chefs
[Applaudissements]
troublant qu'est ce que tu as qu est-ce
que quand on est alors resté d'envoi les
acquis alors dites-nous bas pendant
qu'elle est parti là pendant la pub son
téléphone est allumé gens avec qui à
monsieur qui sait monsieur hees nous
chagrine c'est le grand patron des rg
mais quoi c'est vrai mais pas d'un
vaisseau rigoler bah tiens toi alors dit
la vérité quoi il a envoyé à ce que
c'est alors je vous le dis c'est pas
facile le faire un média christophe nick
et juste en dessous et à chaque caisse
non halal tout point de vue non mais et
donc ils ont envoyé quoi mais ils en
viennent texto grossier achoppé sur mon
nom est ce que moi je sers est en train
de faire la réponse non mais ce qu'on
pouvait lire 3,4 ça va envoyer trois
cadenas oui 3 non mais c'est peut-être
café je sais pas évident mais ça c'est
moi quand vous regardez à la même
personne
non non non nous avons envoyé quoi a
battu l agent et je viens josée dayan
aussi j'ai vu des noms bavière envoyé
quoi bachelot le muter me sens très loeb
ce soir pour en vue d'une bonne table
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
effectivement tu va encore avoir des
points bas et aimer c'est énorme ça à
mon avis rien voir oui il s'appelle mon
niveau attendez je vais dire le message
c'est vrai j'ai vu isabelle moi une
image qui m'a envoyé un message
ouais jabel morini bosc est en jeu c'est
plus que je t'ai mis en vue d'un plan à
trois la dernière personne à avoir de
code source
oui c'est vrai c'est normal et on va
prendre deux trois nouvelles de trois
autres questions s'il vous plaît qu'elle
vous à être une question par claude
alexis merci et l'autre sans frais de la
ramasse total la même qu'une chose ça
les normes il est tranquille on non moi
je bosse tient bien connaître mon avenir
immédiat
tu le connais bien c'est sûr qu'à tout
simplement
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis pas du tout monde ici
franchement c'est fou alors claude
voulez savoir votre avenir immédiat
est-ce que tu as une idée les autres pas
plus un peu là écoutant la radio quand
même ici également à très bien les
nations unies elle continue les deux cas
je vous dire à la l1 s'est dit à la
radio elle est là depuis 50 ans si la
virile format radio mais en plus c'est
rtl
et je voudrais dire et sert en plus je
m'entends très bien avec votre peau
grands patrons qui est très sympathique
à moisn lecouls mas des rations
honnêtement investirait bon voilà est
donc maintenant bon j'ai acquis fin au
point de faire des plans mais elle a
gardé une question offert cinq dernières
questions la journée j'aimerais savoir
oui c'est d'oser me marier bientôt je
désire en 2018 a déjà et un bulbe est
encore 2018 n'implose 2018 montre les
canes mariage ses promotions 2018 la
maternité peut se vivre fin 2010 et
début 2010 bientôt là mathieu vous avez
envoyé alors qu'on vient de me dire
alors ayez il a envoyé un message du
portable d'isabelle morini-bosc au
directeur général d'aj 2 haut de la
boîte de production s'est dit philippe
stoltz
non mais quoi vous avez envie vous voyez
quoi je sais rien j'ai très vite j
allais les revendre au regard des faits
n'était pas la même chose d'autre dit je
vais regarder
faut il le dire dès que vous l'avez clay
wilson le directeur général ce qu'on
fait là ne m'a répondu ah et ce n'est
pas ce que tu m'emmerdes resterait pas
là c'est parce que vous avez mis à mal
un jeu 10 et 7 ans manuele revient là on
a des retours
j'ai mis pardon c'est un missile de
mathieu retour gpat l'abîmé la voilà
regardez qu'est ce que vous avancez
janvier bruno masure hausse
résumé me me sens qu'une bonne note ce
soir à la télé people
non mais c'est faux nous avons envoyé
quoi envie de tête up ça passe j'suis
désolé pas ça passe comme si on envoyait
15 ça passait le week-end à mon chef
direct à qui comme elle s'appelle dit au
tony anthony a while on voit qu'on a
entendu votre chef direct à 23 heures on
a envoyé le week end je t'emmerde
surtout de s'adapter
cette année je t'emmerde surtout frais à
wayne quand même fallu aller droit au
coeur
ça sent la grosse annonce rien allez on
va prendre ce problème qui savait qu ici
c'est énorme ce qui se passe parce que
ça aux bandes en parler pendant des
années olivier fogiel géant midi
[Applaudissements]
je t'aime à ce poste je t'aime matthieu
pichot et mais les mecs ça va toucher là
à l'aîné dernière isabelle si honteux
qui travaillaient alors d'interdire les
pour noter ses mac russie a envoyé quoi
macro non un procédé classique josée
dayan me sens très loeb ce soir ouais
super projet fait le tour je pense qu'on
a pu leur on a déjà bien quatre très
belles jamais j'ai une heure à dormir
j'ai passé une heure à répondre mais je
fais des réponses trop longue
brooks